i'll give you an example of an out of
control corporation spirit airlines
just punished
some travelers a young family now some
people say that traveling on spirit
airlines is punishment enough
it is in itself punishment i've traveled
on that airline quite a bit because it's
pretty cheap
there was a family young woman seven
months pregnant
got young kids special needs kid
they're all wearing their masks the
little little kid was not wearing a mask
and some crazy stewardess at spirit
airlines
demanded that they leave the plane take
a listen
non-compliance you will have to get off
i don't want to do this
you have to pick up your stuff what do
we do
i'm sorry how much you are okay no
problem we did
not compliance with the mass we're
bringing them
i'm sorry i'll make sure he wears it
everything's gonna be fine
i'm sorry i'll make sure that they're
wearing it okay
specially styled two-year-olds i
understand
right i'm not my toys
non-compliance beep boop make the baby
and the special needs kid wear the mask
beep boop beep boop non-compliance get
off now
no i don't think so i don't think
corporations should be allowed to do
that
i don't think that spirit airlines is a
private company
in this very abstract way that we like
to think of this firm distinction
between public and private i think there
is a
a lot of government regulation of these
airlines
and and the governments are bringing up
the mass mandates but in some cases the
corporations are pushing it more than
the government
and i just don't care i care about the
practical effect of this
what what happened on that airline is
unjust
should not be permitted to happen in a
just society
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
you